it seems like everywhere I go everyone's
talking about the recession from
increased grocery prices to how
expensive everything is getting and even
though I've cut out many expenses over
the years through our experience with
minimalism there's a few things that
I've done differently or that I plan on
doing differently this year in order to
save more money
so today I'm going to be sharing with
you the 15 items that I do not plan on
buying this year and hopefully these
quick money saving tips will not
necessarily serve as strict rules but
more of as a guide in the hopes that
some of these can help you cut your own
expenses in places that you may not have
considered the first item on the list is
unnecessary vitamins and I use the word
unnecessary specifically because I'm
somebody that does value taking vitamins
so for example I definitely want to be
taking a vitamin D because it's
important for thyroid health and because
I have Hashimoto's that's something that
I definitely want to keep taking but
when I was looking through my expenses
on a monthly basis to try to figure out
where I could cut back on I realized
that vitamins was an area that I could
tweak back a little bit what I mean by
this is that I was taking a multivitamin
that already had vitamin D3 in it and I
was taking a vitamin D3 supplement
separately so when I cut that out I
eliminated nine dollars per month just
specifically from doing that then I went
to look at my Vitamin B and I realized
that the percentage says to take two
capsules per day but the daily value is
well above 100 so really in reality I
could take one capsule per day and cut
my expenses in half without actually
having to stop taking these things all
together because these little things add
up over time item number two on the list
is birthday cakes so John just had a
birthday and I could not bring myself to
go to the store and spend twenty or
thirty dollars on a small cake that I
could very well make myself at home for
well under five dollars I had most of
the ingredients so really I just
basically went out and bought some stuff
to make some whipped cream and I let him
have at it at decorating his own cake
that was definitely a lot more fun so
now going forward I'm definitely going
to make it more of an experience of
decorating our own cake together rather
than going to the store and purchasing
this item for a much more expensive
price item number three is groceries
without comparing the price per unit of
measure groceries have definitely been
rising in price and you may have heard
the hack of shopping for generic brands
in order to save you money but if you
haven't looked at the unit of measure
you may want to look into that so for
example I buy almond milk every single
week recurrently and when I went to look
at the different containers that they
had they looked like they were a similar
size but one was measured in gallons and
one is measured in liters it could be
easy for me to look at the prices and
say Well they're very similar prices and
they look like a similar container but
if I actually calculate the price per
the unit of measure I can clearly find
the cheaper option that I can buy
recurring and that way it will save
money not only on that purchase but
every single week thereafter item number
four is purchasing items that I will
rarely use so sticking with the cake
example we don't own a mixer for the
very few times a year that I actually do
make a cake a whisk will do or I can
borrow it from a family member or a
friend I'm definitely warming up to the
idea that sometimes either borrowing or
finding a different solution such as the
Whisk can be much more beneficial
financially for those items that are
rarely going to be used number five is
complicated skin care regimens in the
past I definitely was somebody that
would buy all sorts of serums and
different things for my face and I found
that my skin Health has definitely
improved through my nutrition and
through the supplements that I take and
because of that I've been able to really
Pare down the items that I use to a very
minimal view the items that I use on a
routine basis are basically coconut oil
as my moisturizer
my foaming Castile soap is my face wash
and then my tinted sunscreen and lip
balm slash blush
and that's it I've found that I don't
need all those other complicated serums
and multi-step processes that never
really did anything for me other than
deplete my wallet item number six is
items for work that are not truly
necessary and this really applies more
to people that have like office type
jobs so for me for example I'm a nurse
and I work for an employer so not
necessarily for people that work like
Contracting that need tools in order to
work I know of some people that really
love to make their office space feel
like a home away from home and so they
decorate and they get for example that
golden stapler to make it just kind of
cozy and nice and if this works for you
and it makes you happy then great power
to you but I think of it this way the
more money that I spend on work the more
time that I have to spend at work rather
than with my family and my priority is
the second so I have been wearing the
same rickety torn up scrubs for a while
and I should probably replace them if I
cared about being presentable but
because I go to work to make money not
to spend money I'm going to keep wearing
them and my old nursing shoes until they
just can't go any further I also don't
spend any money on work Gatherings or
just work related events if there's free
food and it's free I'm game but if I
have to pay money to go or to buy any
particular item in order to be there you
can assume that I will most likely not
be there there is a caveat to this and
that is that I really value giving I
think that giving changes Us in that it
helps remove our greed and it helps us
improve a mindset of prosperity and
contentment so for example when three of
my co-workers got pregnant around the
same time I contributed towards that but
that doesn't mean that I'm going to pay
for the luncheon learns or that I'm
going to buy colorful scrubs with all
sorts of different patterns that I will
definitely pass on number seven is
disposable items from menstrual care to
sponges to cloth napkins wherever there
is a reusable option I will opt for that
I've mentioned reusable items before I
actually have two two different videos
for a total of 50 disposables that you
can swap out for the reusable to save
the environment to save money and to
save time to and from the store to get
these items but this year I have a
couple of different new ones the example
that I'll share with you is that I use
two hey terrainy cloudy days and here in
Georgia especially in Winter it just
seems like it's dark all the time and so
to make these gloomy days a little bit
more cozy I bought some fairy lights and
some faux candles but to avoid
constantly spending on batteries I
purchased a rechargeable set and voila
coziness without the monthly expense
number eight is workout equipment over
the last few years I've definitely been
focusing on improving my health and
fitness is definitely something that I
am interested in but I now have realized
that there's not a whole lot of things
that I actually need I used to have
treadmill and a whole bunch of different
equipment but I found that body weight
exercises have really been my favorite
so I now just basically have a yoga mat
and some bands without having to have
all these things taking up room in my
home or spending more money on these
things that I may or may not actually
end up using I also think that it can be
really helpful to kind of prove it to
yourself that you built this habit of
doing whatever particular activity you
want to do before you go buy those items
for that activity building the habit of
actually exercising before you go out
and buy the treadmill and then realize
that you never used it and then you feel
guilty getting rid of it because you
didn't use it number nine is baskets and
organizers I think this is definitely
important if you want to cut back on
buying more items because we can often
think of decluttering as organizing and
they're not the same thing if we have
this particular piece of furniture or
basket or box or whatever it might be
it's just like our natural tendency to
want to stuff it with things and fill it
up because it's empty and I need to take
advantage of this space and if we buy a
basket just because it's cute and we
don't necessarily have something to put
in it it's much more likely that we're
gonna find some things to put inside
that basket so I'm deciding that I'm not
going to go down that Rabbit Trail and
we'll just eliminate that all together
I'm definitely not getting rid of the
ones I already have though because I'm
I'm a lover of baskets number 10 is
purses jewelry or accessories over the
years I have gotten rid of my brand name
purses I'm no longer interested in those
sorts of things but this last year I got
rid of my Apple watch and my Michael
Kors watch and that hurt honestly it was
difficult because I had this particular
item that at one point I enjoyed wearing
at one point it was part of my style but
I realized that I had to be honest with
myself that even when I force myself to
put it on as a trial to see if I would
actually wear it again I didn't feel
comfortable in it it was no longer
representative of my style or who I am
or what I want in life I just want the
particular items that are my favorite
that I'm gonna go to every single day
and so unless for example my purse rips
and I can't fix it I will not be
purchasing any more this year number 11
is a simple one but it's home decor so
things like table runners or seasonal
Decor things like that in the past I
used to definitely want to decorate
especially for Christmas time because
it's my favorite but this last year
besides our Christmas tree and our
Nativity I was very minimal with our
decorations and actually I had pine
cones that we could just paint and put
glitter on I also used to be one that
would love to change out the runners on
the table and just different decor for
Different Seasons or different holidays
and I have totally eliminated that and I
just want to admire the beauty of our
handmade table that my husband made
number 12 is alcoholic drinks I don't
know how many times I'm going to like
admit to these things that last year I
purchased the Moonshine just because I
wanted to try it I was in Tennessee and
I realized I didn't like it so I had to
toss it but when I was decluttering a
refrigerator I realized that we have a
bottle of tequila that has been there
for over two years that clearly means
that we do not drink those things so we
don't need to be purchasing any more of
these items just so they can sit in our
fridge and take up space and not only
that but it's expensive stuff number 13
is makeup unless I run out of something
I don't plan on buying any more makeup
this year because I found my go-to
Basics and honestly besides my tinted
sunscreen and my lip balm slash blush in
one I don't really wear makeup except
for maybe once a week or when we have a
special occasion or event so I do not
need to be purchasing any more of these
items this year number 14 is saving
products last year I invested in a
safety razor as well as a box of blades
and between these two purchases it is
enough that I will not have to purchase
any more shaving products this year and
as far as like a shaving cream Maybe
basically just use soap and water and
then follow up with coconut oil as a
moisturizer so that is an expense I have
definitely slashed completely from this
year number 15 is a weird one but it's
something that I really wanted to share
with you because it's been really
helpful to me and that is pillows and
pillowcases okay hear me out when I had
John I had really bad sciatic pain and
so I was seeing a chiropractor and
trying to work on my posture because I'm
really bad at that and I need to work on
that but one of the things that he told
me is to sleep without a pillow so that
I could sleep flat on my back and at
first it was really really difficult
because I'm a crazy sleeper I do all
sorts of really weird poses when I'm
sleeping but the more I did it the more
I found Improvement my posture and my
spinal health and just that pain that
would not go away I do not plan on
buying any more pillows or pillowcases
or just pillow related stuff for sleep
let me know do you sleep with a pillow
or could you ever see yourself sleeping
flat without a pillow I'd love to hear
from you in the comments below and bonus
number 16 is the higher more expensive
phone data plans I work as a home nurse
meaning that I visit patients in their
home and so I do need internet for GPS
and a hotspot as well but because I have
had instances where my phone loses
signal and I'm in the middle of nowhere
I typically plan my routes before I
actually head into the home and I find
that because I'm on my phone a lot for
work it can be really easy to justify
that I need that higher speed internet
because it's for work so this year I
decided that I'm going to take that
unlimited data plan and just take it
back a notch for two different reasons
one of course it can save me money but
two I think that it kind of forces me to
be more aware of the data that I am
using because once that high speed ran
out I had to wait until the next cycle
for it to start all over again so those
are my 15 16 things that I do not plan
on purchasing this year but let me know
what are some ways that you plan on
putting back on your own expenses let us
know down in the comments below so that
we can all learn more ways to save more
money and if you like this video give it
a thumbs Up And subscribe so you won't
miss when I post a new video I think so
much for watching and I'll see you in
the next one bye for now